the sequel to the shitty movie
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen which
is the movie that started all things
YouTube for me that's right without
transformers - you wouldn't have me or
at least my videos so let's do this
Transformers Dark of the Moon alright so
after hating transformers - so much I
was curious I was like how is this movie
gonna be I mean the trailers looked like
it was gonna be a cool movie that's all
I wanted at this point I wasn't hoping
for like Amadeus or something and was it
good it's actually kind of like two
movies really which makes sense because
the movies like an hour and 40 minutes
long it's absurd but the first half of
the movie deals a lot with Sam and his
new girlfriend I don't know her name
like Victoria's Secret model number 269
and the big question is is she better
than you that other chick whose name I I
hate her so I'm not gonna pronounce her
name if I'm gonna color sandwiches cuz
it's a degrading and fitting name and I
can't stand her and it all works so this
new chick is actually a lot better than
sandwiches was in the first day because
with sandwiches I was like I can't
really she doesn't look like she wants
to date this dude I never bought their
romance she just looks like a chick who
was along for the ride cuz you know he
had a car who could transform and kill
[ __ ] edge but this new chick she's
actually pretty cool her character was
actually pretty likable I didn't want to
like I wanted to be like yeah a
Victoria's Secret model who cares good
job BAE but all in all I - a couple
parts where I'm like dude you're being
an obnoxious chick don't do that she was
actually pretty cool so it was alright
they had fun relationship banter also so
I bought it with sandwiches no but in
the first half of the movie you see a
lot of [ __ ] that you hated in the second
movie like that really cheesy humor
you're sitting there going hey this is
what I hated about the second one - I
thought we learned I thought you were
gonna make up for this kind of [ __ ]
there's too little comedy relief
transformers it all looked too familiar
but I did like how it touched on Sam's
not happy because he doesn't want a job
he wants to matter and his role with
transformers is really done until a new
adventure awaits him and John Turturro
wise John Turturro in the movie at all
I'm not saying he was overly obnoxious
there were like three other John Tudor
house in the movie to take his place of
obnoxious I'm just saying if his
character was just eradicated never in
the movie at all the movie would be no
different just having him in at this
point is just Forrest it's kind of like
heroes by like season two or three Matt
Parkman had no place stopping but then
at a point [ __ ] gets real when
Armageddon rains from the skies the
Decepticons invade and they start wiping
things out we're not talking like
they're transforming the cars and flying
away no the like eradicating the human
race like they show falling skies how
you hear about six months ago the human
this was wiped out but you never see it
this is a story of what happened
kindness and that's the last half maybe
last hour of the movie and it's like a
whole movie in itself it is so much
awesome destruction which is all I
wanted to see in the movie I mean
Autobots are getting wiped out people
are getting wiped out buildings are
falling down the only problem is there
is so much of this going on at a point
you keep watching it you're like I did
that's it's still a lot of destruction
nothing else just explosions and those
Michael Bay splosions that have like you
know white fireworks in them it is cool
to see but that's like all you get it's
like the show man versus food it's so
much you don't know if you can handle
all of it at once but on this battle
this day goes to man or Decepticons
really however the ending is way too
abrupt
I mean Optimus Prime is like skating on
the pavement like twirling around just
killing robots it's all sorts of badass
in the last conflict happens it's like
metal and explosions at war it has all
come down to this and then it ends and
then a monologue happens like and that's
how it is because we're Autobots and we
kick ass mother flan Ananda and credit
song and then it's over it's like a whoa
who had 13 seconds ago I was watching a
battle now I'm watching end credits
that's I guess that's how it goes down
sounds like the studio's like all right
over budget wrap it up seriously the
second movie suck you don't get it for
us in fact you don't get the end to a
third you just get credits so first half
was a bit annoying and comedic it took a
little while to get going then it got
going and it was awesome be it only
battles but it was everything I want to
battle LA to be so that was cool and
then it just ends what really got me
into the movies when I saw Optimus Prime
with a sword and a shield when Robo
Jesus gets all xcalibur on you I'm like
I am there so I would say Transformers
Dark of the Moon is a good time no
alcohol required so Transformers Dark of
the Moon have you seen it are you going
to see it what's your favorite
Transformers movie in fact what's your
favorite moment of any Transformers
movie comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you